is college a waste of time in today's
world asks matthew
no it's not i know there's a whole
movement against college
and one of the reasons there's a
movement against college comes from
people who've
done extremely well either while they
were in college and dropped out
mark zuckerberg mark zuckerberg or had
good fortune and didn't need the college
and so they stand up and say you don't
need college i didn't need college
well that's true some people don't need
it but there's more to college than
simply the
subjects that we learn do we need the
subjects in college
not really most of the stuff we'll study
in college we won't need
in future in our future and it won't
help us be successful
but we're learning more than that in
school we're learning how to interact
with other people for many of us it's
the first time we
we've left home we're learning to fend
for ourselves do our own laundry
get a job provide for ourselves budget
our money that's a new one
for many people they're living in dorms
they're learning to interact
they're learning independence they're
learning self-reliance it's also the
first time in a classroom
where your professors will expect you to
disagree in high school
largely you do as you're told you take
the test and that's it in college it's
about discussion and it's about
disagreement and sometimes there are no
right
answers so one of the things you'll
learn is how to disagree
how to form an argument there is so much
more that you
learn in college that will help you in
the rest of your life that have
nothing to do with the subjects that
you're going to learn
in other words choose your classes based
on the quality of your professors
not based on how easy the classes are or
sometimes even just what the subject is
yes college still has value in our lives